The joe rogan experience.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
they're,
they're little helicopter.
What the fuck did people do before they figured out tents?
Uh,
well the Eskimos,
I believe that they smeared fat on their skin that would,
certain kinds of fat would keep the mosquitoes off them.
I think got all sorts of really clever adaptations.
You know,
you know,
we,
we sort of assume that we would be helpless,
but that's because we didn't grow up there and our culture didn't,
you know.
Right.
So there's,
you know who,
Wade Davis is a,
he's a,
he's an anthropologist.
He's written a bunch of books.
Really interesting guy.
He's,
um,
like anthropologists in residents at the Smithsonian in Washington.
He wrote a book called the wayfarers I think was his last book about
traditional,
like,
about how these guys could navigate across the Pacific.
Just looking at the stars and the color of the water and smelling and whatever
they'd,
anyway,
he,
uh,
one of the stories he tells us about this,
Eskimo guy,
old guy,
and the family sort of took the keys to the car away from him.
Like,
you can't go anymore.
They were afraid he would go out and die the traditional way.
When Eskimo people got old,
they would just like wander off into the ice and die.
So as not to be a burden to the family.
Right.
And he was a traditional guy and they were worried that he would take the,
the snow machine out and just die out there somewhere or hurt himself hunting or
whatever.
So they had this whole intervention.
And so that night he goes out,
gets out of the house,
takes a shit in his hand,
forms the shit into a knife,
blade spits on it and the spit a is freezing along the edge and he hones that
down.
So he gets a nice sharp edge with his sped,
takes his shit knife,
kills a dog or a couple of dogs and takes their,
uh,
ribs and makes us a sled out of it.
And with the sinews and whatever other pieces of the dogs,
you know,
he knew all this stuff from his childhood,
hooks up a couple of other dogs to the sled and he takes off into the,
into the snow on his,
you know,
sled with his shit knife.
Wow.
Oh my God.
That might be the most of the same story I've ever heard.
We didn't know any better.
Yeah,
we didn't know any better idiots.
We were like 1920 that we,
we used to fucking go out and drink like a 12 pack of beer and eat McDonald's at
one in the morning.
And by like eight o'clock we were unloading trucks,
fine,
laughing and then we would work.
We do all this shit and that during the lunch hour we would go out and play
basketball and like just regular sneakers and like five o one blues.
Remember that the black fly and you'd be out there.
You come back and pouring sweat and then just keep,
it's in great shape.
I was ever in it my life.
And then in the end of work I would then go lift and go ride a bike.
Dude,
I'm at one time I want a bike ride hammered.
I was so into working out fucking bike ride.
I'm on like a 12 speed bike that I bought when I still have it by the way in my
garage I refuse to throw shit out and a,
I remember being hammered on the bike and I'm sweating so I'm becoming more
hammered.
I was going to do this 11 mile loop and then it became oh seven and then I just
kinda came back and I was like on the bike laughing and I was like 2021 and was
only beginning to understand the fragility of life and I knew that what I was
doing was stupid,
but I couldn't get,
I,
I just kept picturing my friends laughing at me and I was literally by myself
riding this bike,
laughing drunk,
driving up the street
and you have a two and a half hours.
Like I'm just taking snippets from fucking the eighties I got,
I got nothing left
used to be able to bounce back so well when you're young,
it's amazing.
When you're 20 years old,
you get hammered the next day.
You barely feel anything.
Dude,
Donald's in tear down that place.
I would get to quarter pounders with cheese,
a large fry,
a six piece mcnugget and I never liked him.
I never liked him.
I never thought an ace to try the different sauces.
I used to go with the mustard,
never tastes good.
I just wanted something to fill the void.
And then I would get like a couple of cheeseburgers and uh,
I think it just a giant coke and just throw that down and wake up the next day
with a flat stomach.
And I had already drank like,
you know,
eight,
nine beers.
We've got to fight.
We got into a fight one time right under the Golden Arches and the next town
over.
I Dunno what happened.
These guys came in drunk,
classic Boston shift.
They just come walking in and,
and give everybody the finger.
Of course we respond to it and next thing you know,
we're out underneath the golden arches.
There's like five of us in two of them.
And my buddy,
we always fought,
he starts swinging on the big one and then the little one,
he sort of jumped and it just became this big,
it looked like wrestling,
you know,
when like they all come running out of the dressing and to help each other.
We're on snow,
everybody's drunk just fallen down.
We was so fucking drunk.
The cops were there sort of misting mace for like,
and I don't know how long,
like we didn't even see him pull up this just like being in the light.
Then all of a sudden everybody's like eyes it like cheering up and shit.
And then what was hilarious was they just broke us up and they fuck it.
And then like two seconds later we're back in our car and the same two guys we
were fighting were coming back up to the car and say,
what did the cops go?
I thought it was over.
And the guy's like,
that was a bullshit pudge.
I'm under the little one goes,
I said,
ma'am,
he goes,
we laugh at you a shit.
It was fucking nuts.
I gotta give it up to him.
And it was,
it was,
you know,
fucking four on two whatever.
And uh,
they didn't give a shit.
They laughed.
They definitely laughed at our shit.
They didn't care.
They ate that Mason,
they came right back.
They already right up to our face right up to our Ford escort.
They did not give a fuck if you're still into the fight and he just got amazed.
That's what you need.
That thing happened because I don't,
nobody got it full on.
Like it was just like you're,
I,
I thought we thought it was the snow.
Like they had thrown rock salt cause we were on the ground and I don't know what
it was,
but it was just like unbelievably fucking air.
But we were hammered.
That sounds like a fucking police car pulled up and nobody noticed.
That's hilarious.
Whatever was going on.
What do you believe are the components of,
of dream telepathy?
Have you isolated it down to a certain,
firing the synapses?
Do you mean,
do you have any idea of what,
what causes it?
We have the equipment to do much more with the brain now than we could.
You have to remember the parasite ecologists don't have very much money and
don't have the tools to,
uh,
to utilize a lot of this equipment.
But what we did on our studies was very,
very simple.
The nights that the dreams hill apathy seemed to be successful were the nights
that the geo magnetic fields of the earth were very calm,
very few sunspots,
very few electrical storms.
And so one could hypothesize that there is a field of some sort of global field
were these barely detectable influences and very subtle means of communication
that can sneak through.
Also,
by and large,
if there is an emotional connection between the people who are in contact with
each other over a distance,
it's more likely to happen than if they're complete strangers.
Didn't you have some sort of a crazy psychic vision of Kennedy being
assassinated?
Well,
actually I did the Alphas dre.
My very first silicide been experience that I had the courtesy of Timothy leary
who I went to Harvard to visit and who invited me to an experiment of silicide
mills was a beautiful and glorious experience yet was don during the days when
psilocybin was legal,
in fact,
as one of his last legal siliciden sessions.
And there was only one Downer during that experience.
And that was when I had the actual decision during psilocybin with my eyes
closed of President Lincoln being shot.
And I saw the gun at the base of his profile and somebody screamed out,
the president has been shot.
And then Lincoln space morphed into that of Kennedy.
And there was the rifle,
except now it was not a pistol as his rifle.
And somebody who's screaming,
the president has been shot.
I recorded all of that.
I had such an incredible experience.
I made dozens of copies and Santa to my close friends.
And of course in several months the tragedy of Kennedy's death actually
happened.
And so my vision,
whether it was coincidental or pre-cognitive,
was on record.
And that'll be considered myself a highly psychic person.
You don't consider yourself,
um,
did that freak you out at all?
Yeah.
No.
Nothing's preached me off in this field.
It's just a surprise at sometimes leaves me a,
a sense of wonder because there's more things going on in the world we don't
take seriously,
or they'll take us by surprise.
[inaudible].